well super bowl 55 it is just three days
away now security of course it's always
crucial
but this year officials are preparing
for a range of unprecedented potential
threats
kevin martin live from tampa this
morning with more on that security plan
hey kevin good to see you
well good morning alex and good to hear
your voices well yeah the super bowl is
the biggest sporting spectacle
in the u.s each year and because of its
national significance it is classified
as a seer one event and that is
top tier security ranked just below a
presidential inauguration and
that's just a normal year and this year
as you mentioned there are
additional post threats for super bowl
55
and officials say they're prepared and
ready for their game plan
and executed on sunday we all know that
football is a team sport
but security is a team sport as well
just as the buccaneers and chiefs will
be operating their finely tuned game
plans come sunday
on the field so will hundreds of federal
state and local security professionals
off of it while the football teams are
on the field we will be all around it
long before tom brady became a buccaneer
or before patrick mahomes and the chiefs
ended kansas city's 15-year super bowl
title drought last season in miami
officials have been preparing their game
plan for super bowl 55. you know plans
for events of this nature go out 18
months
and in your planning process you look
for
the upper limit of what you think you
might need to do to secure the event
overall and it's not just the event
venue itself but it's the surrounding
area and just like we will most likely
see
some audibles called at the line of
scrimmage this massive security
operation will also be adapting on the
fly
to an ever-changing security picture you
know threats change all the time and a
good plan
allows you to adjust things that you had
planned to do based on the threats that
you're seeing
while this super bowl will be played
under unprecedented threat conditions
with a national domestic terrorism
advisory in place
and the covet pandemic law enforcement
has it covered
the only thing we want you to worry
about is who will win the game
please leave the rest of worrying to us
while there will be heightened awareness
surrounding super bowl 55 it was
reiterated by
several officials at this panel that
there is no specific
credible threat at the present time but
they will be ready
should something happen reporting live
in tampa kevin martin eight sports now
oh yeah we're getting close all right
kevin thanks so much for joining us this
morning hope you have fun there in tampa
it looks
a little bit warmer today so thank you
so much